[Music]
my name is Jani Chicano MA from Greece
and I speak 32 languages Russian
Portuguese I honest is what we call a
hyper polyglot it means he can speak a
lot of languages by the time I was 20 I
had already learned some 15 languages
and when I moved to Brussels and started
my career or the EU institutions I added
more official EU languages see the thing
is I honest he's a quick learner
I Spencer no ideas for not mm mama I see
Tyler mckernon see how why call you yes
this doesn't happen by just sitting at
home in the studying no no clarity no I
K viajar is very potato con la gente
netted Lamia procrastinate pres nian
no it rears occur to any metal Jonnie
Jonnie [ __ ] till redneck : mark a post
so you desire veramente to the Questor
lingua con in economy ecology only
Giorno the world is a big place with
different cultures and yes different
languages a clifton Levanon letter
inspiration in italian and meter marine
dental I speak to my husband in polish
Polish polish I dream in all kinds of
languages targeted Solanki share please
difficult calm did not reverse the move
wailing before we go if anyone knows
it's you what is the most complicated
language to learn Mandarin
mystery solved
[Music]
hello normally when you think of words
they fit into a language but there's a
relatively new class of words that don't
quite follow the rules and it's called
wasa a go John Kelly is a language
writer I spend a lot of my time writing
about word origins
he's a linguistics expert and he knows
just about everything about the
phenomenon called wasa a go why say a go
literally means Japan made English it is
a language process that takes foreign
words usually English words and
transmogrifies them into something
wholly new and novel for Japanese
purposes we see this with a word like
karaoke everybody knows and everybody
loves karaoke but it joins the Japanese
kata which means empty and okay which is
a Japanese rendering of orchestra so a
karaoke is an empty orchestra the most
popular example is the word Pokemon the
creator of Pokemon took two English
words pocket and monster he smashed them
together and got Pokemon or take cosplay
a word that describes people dressing up
as fictional characters cosplay joins
costume in play and there's anime anime
is a fairly straightforward rendering of
the English animation Wasi ego is
important because language is always
changing and reinventing itself
what new words will pop up in the future
only time will tell
[Music]
pardon me professor maybe you can help
me out here is this word pronounced cash
or cash a cash appreciate it doc you see
when jock Bailey pronounces a word he
pronounces it right he could pronounce
this thing it's my Ragan he can
pronounce this thing
Sharron shmitah he even pronounces words
that don't make a lick of sense albumen
and when you're that damn good with
words sooner or later someone's gonna
pay you to say him hi dr. Bailey
this is jock Bailey the official
pronounced er of the National Spelling
Bee Luxembourg L you XE
[Music]
Gayla sherbet Giro
GIF before jocks days is the world's
foremost pronounce our persnickety words
he began a spelling career on the other
side of the microphone jock was a
competitive speller and in 1980 he found
himself in the finals of the Scripps
National Spelling Bee his word aloo cube
rate so he said elu CU b ra t and it
means to burn the midnight oil to study
all night and with those 10 letters jock
became a champion 23 years later jacket
aloo ki braided all the way to the Big
Show propio phenom Roquefort pyroclastic
the definition but sometimes even
Chuck's meticulous pronunciations don't
tell the whole story English words are
not always felt as they sound one thing
that makes English words really hard to
spell is the schwa the schwa is that uh
like in butter or unutterable the y and
syringe the a in balloon the Olin
freedom they all sound the same spoken
out loud a spellers nightmare
the longer and weirder a word is the
easier it is to spell take take the
state fish of Hawaii the homo homo no ko
well the humuhumunukunukuapua'a that's
an easy word to spell it's just long
it's a weird word and weird things stand
out and are easier to remember oh and oh
and a si a pair in Amasia correct for a
man with perhaps the most legitimate
claim is the authority on pronunciation
Jacques takes a rather agnostic approach
to the right and wrong ways to say
things a lot of people are kind of
amazed that I know how to pronounce all
these words but I don't I read them from
the dictionary well how does the
dictionary know how to pronounce a word
because they go out there and listen to
native speakers if there are a whole
bunch of people who pronounce a word a
certain way that makes it a correct
pronunciation people who have very
strong opinions that there's an
incorrect way to pronounce a word but
it's like saying that dog barked wrong
that's not a bark
well the dog gets to decide thanks John
I reckon you got more wisdom that all
the books in the library in many parts
of the world
Scrabble is viewed as a pastime as a
game where maybe old people play after
retirement and all that but Scrabble in
danger is actually very big it is seen
as a spot there is an actual nature and
Scrabble Federation under the Ministry
of sports they have a lot of young
people hoping to aim an actual living
from playing Scrabble
my name is Wellington g-gary and I'm the
word Scrabble champion I start playing
Scrabble in 1996 when my immediate
Arabella taught me the game it was it
until six years after that I was playing
with some of my neighborhood friends and
they were like ah you are quite good why
not play in tournaments and I was like
wow you mediate ladies in tournaments
and the rest is history else to say
having an African mean the word Scrabble
championship is bigger than I can
actually comprehend you needed to have
been in the hole to see the jubilation
of our other African brothers it was
something that everyone in Africa that
play Scrabble has actually looked
forward to Nigeria is a very very
diverse nation we have well over 500
developed languages but the major means
of communication all over Nigeria is
English and since Scrabble is based upon
the English vocabulary is going to be a
way of helping each and every one
improve their command of the English
language relating with
if I hadn't played Scrabble might have
been involved in some other not so
legitimate activities and I think
playing Scrabble it keeps you on the
right track we are not blind to the
facts that's the level of unemployment
to the country is very very immense so I
came up with the Wellington foundation
for scramble and mine development in
Africa there's a lot of similarities
between how life actually goes and how
Scrabble goes you get to understand that
is not all the time that you get in your
way you really have to make the best out
of the little that you are given you
know each country is known for a
particular sport Brazil for example is
known for football we are hoping to make
Scrabble in Nigerian sports about if you
mention Scrabble in any part of the
world danger should come to mind
[Music]
to be or not to be that is the question
whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer
the slings and I was a very just
fortunate bounce again to see if
troubles are by opposing end them to die
to sleep to sleep perchance to dream
mother you get micromachine man he
presenting a genuine original class of
almost video things micro machines a lot
of people know me as the micro machine
man or the FedEx guy are terrible
Testaverde from Saved by the Bell or
just that guy who talks fast in fact I
was in the Guinness Book as the world's
fastest talker and so for the last 40
years if you needed a fast talker I was
your go-to guy is that ok did you get
everything you need I mean I can repeat
it again if you want you sure you don't
want to do together
when I was 12 years old I wanted to get
into the Guinness Book of World Records
so I figured the only thing I could
really do since I wasn't gonna eat a car
or swallow lead-pipe was to lock myself
in a room and teach myself fast-talking
and I did that with the hamlet soliloquy
years later I'm at this party fancy
California Beverly Hills party and a
friend of mine is trying to pick up this
valley girl he's from New York and
talking pretty quickly and she looks at
him and says Nick oh my gosh are you
like the world's fastest talker and he
says no as a matter of fact this person
is they called me overnight did one of
my little party routines because I come
up sipping a cup of tea but if I pick
difficult the Pacific Club and a guy
walked over he says that's incredible
I'm a producer and I'm gonna put you on
a show I went on the show and I did the
fast-talking thinking that would be it
and all of a sudden the phone starts
ringing and I'm booked all over the
place and I managed to make a living out
of it I can speak as fast as eleven
words a second now I never do eleven
words a second for TV well let me do
Peter Piper at eleven words a second
pick up I come up to pick up cup up to
feed about fifty difficult to pick up a
cup to feed a puppet then you kind of
hear me going pop pop up but that's
really are you kind of getting but when
you do TV there's visual reinforcement
people see you and do whatever so I do
about seven to eight words a second that
would sound something like now on radio
I have to do it even a little slower
because you have no visual reinforcement
you're not seeing me so that I do about
five to six words a second
so it sounds something like and that's
kind of the secret to my success because
if you can't understand what I'm saying
they're not gonna pay me the big bucks
now the very first commercial I did was
the Federal Express commercial
it is to this day the most award-winning
commercial in the history of advertising
the final scene I'm sitting behind the
desk and I'm going you know Dave what's
the deal with the deal are we dealing
David's deal with Don if it's a deal
with dr. feelgood I'm putting you down
to deal with so I did the thing like 29
times without making a mistake and the
director said to me what are you like a
machine you never make a mistake I said
you want a mistake I'll give you a
mistake the next time so I said David's
a dork with dick down and duck and
that's the take II ended up putting in
the commercial to deal with Dave the
first time I saw it I called this John
it's our little secret although I'm
known as the world's fastest talker I do
not choose to live my entire life in the
fast lane sometimes I just like to take
it all a little slower but sometimes
it's really really good to be test
you
[Music]